protests that started over a rise in
Metro fears have provoked a state of
emergency in Santiago students started
the action 11 days ago
angry about a 4% increase in ticket
prices that found an audience and
Chileans frustrated with a rising cost
of living it's good that young people
are coming out to protest because they
raised the fares but rather than raising
salaries the government is raising fares
the government blames the fair eyes on
rising oil prices in a weaker peso
protesters don't buy that and say their
protest is a ticket to wider concerns
about the economy when the students come
in all at once they're protesting in a
way that many of us who work cannot so
in some ways they can represent us but
it's becoming increasingly violent on
Friday protesters forced the Metro to
shut entirely the city estimates
protesters have caused 700 thousand
dollars worth of damage more than 200
incidents mobs have been caught on
street cameras descending on metro
stations commuters have dodged tear gas
and water cannon as police and
protesters confront each other the
electrical company emailed said a group
of people said it's high-rise building
on fire the blaze could be seen across
the city the protests have gone on a
long time at first it was tolerable but
unfortunately now it's grown too big at
least 130 arrests have been made the
state of emergency gives the government
extra powers to restrict public
gatherings for two weeks soldiers are
being deployed to support wyott police
the government is also trying to
downplay the situation there are 3
million daily metro users our estimates
of the biggest event today is that it
never reached more than a hundred and
fifty protestors at any time and yet
South America's largest metro system is
now shut down from a ticket increase
protestors have tapped into deep
discontent about Chile's economy
Charlotte Valles out